Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Six, Episode Fifteen: family and family life.
The family has undergone big changes in Denmark through the last hundred years.
Especially since the 1960s, families have been influenced by new cultural currents and forms of living together.
Where the family, the nuclear family, kernefamilien, earlier almost always consisted of a man and a woman who were married, and their children, there are today other family types: unmarried cohabiting couples with or without children, couples of the same sex who are married or live in registered partnerships, single parents with children and single people without children.
Marriage between a man and a woman is still the most common form of living together and made up 73 percent of all cohabiting couples in 2026.
But the share of persons who marry has fallen markedly through the years.
For example, 88 percent of all 30-year-old women in 1970 were married, whereas the share in 2026 was only 31 percent.
At the same time both men and women are older than before when they marry for the first time.
That does not however mean that they wait to form couples.
Since the 1970s it has been common, especially among younger people, that couples live together even though they are not married.
Couples who live together without being married, "paperless marriages", do however not automatically have the same legal and financial obligations to each other as married couples.
In Denmark the aim is that homosexuals have the same rights and duties as all other citizens.
It has however not always been so.
Until 1933, sexual relations between persons of the same sex could be punished with a fine or prison.
And only in 1981 was homosexuality removed from the Danish Health Authority's official list of mental illnesses.
But in 1989 Denmark became the first country in the world to give two persons of the same sex the right to enter into a registered partnership, which has largely the same legal effects as a marriage.
Persons of the same sex have since 2012 been able to marry, including to be married in the national church.
The Netherlands introduced in 2001 as the first country in the world this right.
Since 2010, two persons of the same sex have also had the possibility of adopting.
The rainbow flag is a symbol of diversity and equality for LGBT+ persons.
It has also become more common than before that adults live alone.
The number of single adults over 18 has risen sharply.
In 2024, 55 percent of all adults live as singles, that is, they are neither married nor live together with a partner.
The rising share of adults who live alone must be seen, among other things, in connection with it having become more common to get divorced, but it is also influenced by the rising number of elderly people, where one of the spouses has died.
Danish society rests on respect for the individual human being.
This means that men and women have the same rights in political and economic life and in family life with regard to the right to start a family, get divorced and so on.
Children also have rights, even though they are under the age of majority.
The age of majority in Denmark is 18 years.
For example, children under 13 years may not work outside the home.
Parents may not hit their children.
Children who are exposed to violence by their parents, or who are otherwise treated badly, can be forcibly removed by the authorities and placed in care with another family.
When children become 18 years old and thereby of age, they can freely choose how they want to live their lives and with whom.
This means, among other things, that they can enter into marriage.
A man and a woman who wish to marry can enter into marriage in Denmark under certain conditions.
Among other things, both must have legal residence in Denmark and have reached the age of 18.
Marriages in Denmark can only be entered into on a voluntary basis.
It is therefore punishable, strafbart, to try to force someone to enter into a marriage that they do not themselves want.
Forced marriage, tvangsægteskab, can lead to prison, fængsel.
A spouse, whether it is the woman or the man, who does not wish to continue the marriage, has the right to separation for six months and then the right to divorce, skilsmisse.
So divorce is possible even if the other spouse does not want it: the answer to "can a couple be divorced if one party refuses" is yes.
If the couple agree to want a divorce, they can get a divorce immediately.
If they do not agree, a spouse has the right to divorce immediately when there are special circumstances, for example infidelity or violence.
In a marriage the mother and father have joint parental authority, fælles forældremyndighed, over their joint children.
The exams also ask about parents who live together: the starting point is that the father and the mother have it together.
After a divorce the parents continue to have joint parental authority over the children.
If the parents separate, they decide themselves how they will share the responsibility for their joint children.
If one parent wants parental authority alone, it is the court that decides whether the joint parental authority is to continue.
Or whether one of the parents is to have parental authority alone.
Many children live in turns with both parents and get new parents, "papforældre", and siblings, if the parents marry or move in with a new partner.
In Danish: a registered partnership is a registreret partnerskab, and marriage is ægteskab.
Here is your recap for Episode Fifteen.
Marriage is still the most common form of living together, 73 percent of cohabiting couples in 2026.
88 percent of 30-year-old women were married in 1970, and 31 percent in 2026.
Since the 1970s it has been common to live together without being married, but such couples do not automatically have the same obligations.
Until 1933 sexual relations between persons of the same sex could be punished; homosexuality was removed from the list of mental illnesses in 1981; Denmark was the first country in the world with registered partnerships, in 1989; same-sex marriage since 2012, including in the national church; the Netherlands was the first country in the world to introduce it, in 2001; adoption has been possible since 2010.
In 2024, 55 percent of adults live as singles.
The age of majority is 18.
Children under 13 may not work outside the home, and parents may not hit their children.
Marriage requires legal residence and age 18, and must be voluntary; forcing someone is punishable.
Separation is for six months before divorce, unless both agree or there are special circumstances such as infidelity or violence.
Parents have joint parental authority, also after a divorce.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
How old must you be according to Danish law to marry without any special permission?
Option A: At least 14 years.
Option B: At least 16 years.
Option C: At least 18 years.
[DA] Hvor gammel skal man ifølge dansk lov være for at blive gift uden nogen særlig tilladelse?  A: Mindst 14 år  |  B: Mindst 16 år  |  C: Mindst 18 år
The answer is C: At least 18 years.
It appeared in the June 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Mindst 18 år
Question 2.
Does a homosexual couple have the right to enter into a marriage?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Har et homoseksuelt par ret til at indgå ægteskab?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is A: Yes.
It appeared in the November 2020 and May 2023 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Ja
Question 3.
When did persons of the same sex get the right to marry?
Option A: 1972.
Option B: 1992.
Option C: 2012.
[DA] Hvornår fik personer af samme køn ret til at indgå ægteskab?  A: 1972  |  B: 1992  |  C: 2012
The answer is C: 2012.
It appeared in the June 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: 2012
Question 4.
In which year did persons of the same sex get the right to enter into a registered partnership?
Option A: 1955.
Option B: 1972.
Option C: 1989.
[DA] Hvilket år fik personer af samme køn ret til at indgå et registreret partnerskab?  A: 1955  |  B: 1972  |  C: 1989
The answer is C: 1989.
It appeared in the November 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: 1989
Question 5.
According to Danish law, can a married couple be divorced even if one party does not want it?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Kan et ægtepar ifølge dansk lov blive skilt, selvom den ene part ikke ønsker det?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is A: Yes.
It appeared in the June 2021 and November 2023 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Ja
Question 6.
Who normally has parental authority when a father and a mother who are married to each other have a joint child?
Option A: The father and mother together.
Option B: The father.
Option C: The mother.
[DA] Hvem har som udgangspunkt forældremyndigheden, når en far og en mor, der er gift med hinanden, har et fælles barn?  A: Faren og moren i fællesskab  |  B: Faren  |  C: Moren
The answer is A: The father and mother together.
It appeared in the June 2022 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Faren og moren i fællesskab
Question 7.
Who has parental authority as a starting point when a mother and father who live together have a joint child?
Option A: The father and mother together.
Option B: The mother.
Option C: The father.
[DA] Hvem har som udgangspunkt forældremyndigheden, når en mor og far, der bor sammen, har et fælles barn?  A: Faren og moren i fællesskab  |  B: Moren  |  C: Faren
The answer is A: The father and mother together.
It appeared in the November 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Faren og moren i fællesskab
Question 8.
Can you go to prison if you illegally force someone to enter into a marriage?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Kan man komme i fængsel, hvis man ulovligt tvinger nogen til at indgå et ægteskab?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is A: Yes.
It appeared in the May 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Ja
That's the end of this part.
Well done.